now you often hear that Hollywood is out
of touch with the rest of the country so
I decided to get out of Hollywood and
talk to regular people about the movies
so I left the Kodak Theatre and went
down to the Magic Johnson theater let's
take a look what was your favorite movie
this year um alien versus Predator alien
versus Predator now what was your
favorite movie last year last year um
probably saw saw boys you're looking
favorite movie this year I guess
chronicles already it's pretty good
Chronicles of Riddick so you have Vin
Diesel fan of his movies yeah okay now
what was your second favorite movie no
second fragrance sure so it just stops
at Chronicles of Riddick yes that's
correct
did you see sideway yeah northern no I
did did you see Finding Neverland no no
did you see Finding Neverland No did you
see Million Dollar Baby didn't see that
no I didn't did you see Million Dollar
Baby no I sure didn't I can't lie and
I'm not gonna front these people out
here and tell you yeah I seen it
did you see aviator no no do you see the
aviator what that dude I played on the
beach yeah the same guy from the beach
did you see uh white chicks oh yeah I
love white chicks yeah
did you see white chicks yes I love that
movie
did you see white chicks Yasmina
balances
did you see sideway yes did you see
Finding Neverland yes I did
did you see Million Dollar Baby oh yes
did you see white chicks best movie of
the year
they got robbed you just won the Oscar
want you to give your exceptions the
acceptance speech
I want to thank my little sister
definitely my inspiration I want to
thank my mom my dad for bringing fish
you are really up on me step back all
the fans all the directors Harvey whines
dude of course I got so many people that
I want to thank my baby of course little
name is hi baby
what about other babies day I want to
thank my mom my dad my sister's yeah
those who thought I couldn't win one
kiss my back
Hey